today I'm going to talk about operations
I'm going to give you some tips and
tricks sort of shorten the learning
curve make it less more of a learning
hill instead of a learning mountain and
fix some of the common misconfigurations
that I see I don't have a whole lot of
time but you'll still feel free to ask
questions I may reserve the right to cut
you off and proceed on because I've got
about twenty four slides in 30 minutes
so operations cannot fix a bad data
model number one so if your developers
are doing something stupid there is
nothing you can do to help them I mean
we can sort of make things a little bit
better but fundamentally you got to get
the data model right so when I come into
a customer site first I'm going to
explore their use cases figure out you
know how they're doing queries how
they're writing data because from that
you can get a number of reads a number
of writes per second all right after
you've got the number of reads and you
got the number of writes per second you
can figure out how big is my cluster
going to be how much memory do I need
prune owed what's the overall budget
going to be alright so as operations
folks you really need to get your
developers to figure out what your read
and write paths are going to be and only
from that can you derive you know what
am I going to need as far as hardware so
no matter how fast we make Cassandra we
can't go faster than the hardware all
right so if I do a read if it's not in
the CPU cache I go to go to main memory
all right it's not a memory I gotta go
to disk each of these have different
Layton sees so the trick to making
something fast is to move it up the
pyramid the problem is that it's a
pyramid the top is very small the bottom
is big and fat so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to teach you some tricks
for moving this up the pyramid then also
decrease
the lazy of each of these sectors right
like how can we make discs faster how
can we move more of the disk access into
main memory so I'm not hitting the desk
one of the common misconceptions that
people have is that will set up the will
come in will set up Cassandra and will
dedicate eight gigs to the JVM keep and
people say to me well I've got this
server with 192 gigs of memory or 256
gigs of memory why do I need all this
memory if Cassandra's only using 8 gigs
the reason why is that eight gigs is
dedicated to the JVM heap and the
operating system is going to use the
remainder of that memory as the buffer
cache so to cache disk access what the
buffer cache is that the colonel set
knows that disk is expensive like if
we're breaking things down in relative
times if a clock cycle is one second
we're talking eons like literally eons
for disk access like we are waiting
hundreds of thousands of cycles in order
to get something back from disk so the
operating system knows this and says hey
you have a bunch of memory that's not
being used by processes I'm going to
move those chunks of disk into main
memory so that when you do reads from
disk rinat reading from disk you're
reading from main memory this is called
the buffer cache when I'm specking out
hard work for a machine i always tell
people buy as much memory as you can and
the reason being is that you get to
cache more of your disk into main memory
so sizing right this is the main formula
you're going to want for figuring if you
so there's two ways to size the first is
by number of operations per second if
we're talking about a use case that fits
in main memory and then we can talk
about Layton sees later but the number
of operations and cassandra node can
Cassandra cluster can push is determined
by this formula and so the way this
works is my Hardware constant times my
number of nodes times the number of
cores per node / replication factor is
the number of ops per second when I say
ops per second that's number of columns
written per second so if I'm writing a
row with ten columns divide that number
by ten now the hard word obviously has a
large role in this so we're and these
are just pulled from my experience
across many many different customers so
about 3,000 for AWS 4000 for commodities
aspect hardware 12,000 for commodity SSD
hard work these numbers get a 50-percent
boost if you switch to Cassandra 20
these numbers also get a 30-percent
boost if you switch to a new kernel so
if you switched to a boon to from Red
Hat for example because red hat doesn't
ship a 230 Colonel a boon to makes a big
difference what was that so it's a
50-percent performance boost for
switching to cassandra 20 branch so if
you switch to cassandra 20 community or
40 datastax you should see a 50-percent
performance boost also a 30-percent
performance boost by switching to a 30
colonel when you're sizing for latency
let's say I need all of my ninety-nine
point nine percent of operations need to
come in within five milliseconds well
you have to think to yourself well if if
my if I need all rights are all reads to
come back within five milliseconds
that's automatically going to roll out
mechanical disks so that means that all
of my reads need to either come from an
SSD or from main memory if you're
dealing with a small data set or you
have a lot of nodes you know you can
push it all up into main memory using
the buffer cache if you can
then you're talking about SSDs so that
the secret to tuning to an SLA is
finding a cluster that allows you to get
enough resources to match one of these
latency profiles does this make sense
never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever you shared storage if you do you
will get yelled at made fun of the
problem with shared storage is that it's
it's not attached to the machine first
so it's going to have higher Layton sees
second is that you're bound to the
throughput for you're bound to the
throughput of whatever your medium is
your transfer medium so if you does if
you've got 500 disks at the end of a
four gig fibre channel pipe you're not
going to be able to take full advantage
of it you're going to be bandwidth
constraint you're also sharing many many
disks with other people and so their
workloads are going to have an impact on
your work clothes you may be able to get
random reader random write performance
but you won't be able to run compaction
compaction will fall behind so never
ever ever ever ever run shared storage
this if you know data model and shared
storage are the number one number two
results in a bad experience when it
comes to deploying Cassandra so we've
gotten so I'm going to go through some
tuning parameters this should the first
ones will work with both mechanical
discs and SSDs but then we'll gain some
SSD specific tuning stuff so one of the
key things to performance tuning is do
less work so one of the first things
that you can do to do less work is turn
off know a time and no endure a time and
so the operating system and the files
system are keeping track of the last
access times for files so if you're
reading from these files a lot it's
going to be updating the access time in
the file system why do you need that you
don't turn it off warm the buffer cache
so I boot up a node it's going to have
nothing in the buffer cache the memory
is going to be empty so on boot you want
to read your SS tables out to dev null
so that that when you start to do reads
it's already in memory you don't have to
wait for it to come in avoid the cold
kashka say cascades where you've
rebooted a bunch of boxes and now i'm
hitting disk all the time in my latency
has gone through the roof by doing this
you it's quite often that you'll see a
machine going from doing minor reads all
the time even from SSDs to knowing doing
no reads whatsoever you know you look at
the output of iostat and they'll just
you know reads per second will just be
zero which is what you want ideally so
this is another thing about
a buffer cache that can get you in
trouble the operating system will so you
have multiple sockets in the machine
those multiple sockets have different
memory controllers those memory
controllers have chunks of memory that
are allocated to them you don't have a
unified set of memory anymore now it's
possible for one cpu to access memory
for another cpu through the the
transport mechanisms of the bundle board
but that has higher costs so what the
colonel tries to do is limit your read
and write access to memory to the chunk
of memory that's dedicated to that
socket the problem is that that can
result in these CPU going to disk
instead of going to the buffer cache so
you want to turn off that behavior this
helps it it can't totally eliminate it
but it makes your life a lot better next
trick is use SSDs there's no reason to
not use SSDs anymore there are 25 more
twenty five percent more expensive 10x
the performance you know EADS if you're
going to need fewer nodes the the nodes
that you do have are going to be
performing better you're going to have
lower SLA is overall you can use fancy
things like level 2 compaction so when
you do do reads you have to do fewer
seeks in the first place it's there's no
reason not to people try and skimp they
when they what they're doing when
they're looking at hardware costs is
that they're looking at just the upfront
costs are just comparing SAS and SSDs
what they fail to take into account as
the full picture the full picture is
with SSDs you can have fewer machines
and the latencies are going to be lower
in order to get the same behavior you're
going to have to move think more of the
data up in
the memory the buffer cache with more
nodes if you're using mechanical disc
and so it's scrim results in much higher
costs overall so here we get into the
tuning of SSDs so the operating system
is tuned for mechanical disks it doesn't
know you have an SSD so you have to tell
it you have an SSD and by default it's
going to ship with a lot of settings
that aren't great for ssds so the first
one is this read ahead so that's how
many seconds so the the the operating
system is not them it knows that when
you do Asik on disk you probably not
just going to want that one page you're
going to want the page next to it
because very rarely do people just want
4k of data so it's going to attempt to
read ahead more pages in anticipation of
you asking for that other seek right now
if you think about a mechanical disc
when I'm doing to seek I'm actually
moving something physical so it takes
eight milliseconds which is an eternity
so it tries to minimize those seeks so
it'll read ahead for megs three megs
some cases 16 megs of data for every 4k
that you request in SSDs random seeks
are free there's no reason to do that so
you could be doing let's say one Meg of
true throughput but then because of read
ahead you're asking the disk to do 16
megabytes per second of actual
throughput so by setting this read ahead
to eight which it should be for most
SSDs you're eliminating that you'll see
SSD seek time go from six milliseconds
down to 100 200 microseconds
if you have really fast SSDs then you
can possibly set it to zero but it's
typically a good starting point that's
the number of yeah what's the default
256 256 which is way too high and well
actually so it's 256 for the actual
drives if you set up a raid drive like
let's say you were using raid 0 on top
of this the operating system by default
is going to set it to 4096 which is just
crazy town so disable that you want to
disable it on all the underlying disks
and on the raid volumes yeah yeah yeah
it makes a huge difference huge
difference same thing for schedulers the
disks have schedulers associated with
each one you need to tell it to use no
op and no this is not a rotational disk
so you end these settings unfortunately
are reset with the arm with every reboot
so you want to put that in your startup
scripts and you again you want to do
this for every single Drive both the
rate volumes and the underlying disks
compaction it's this simple mechanical
disks gets you sighs tiered and SSD
views leveled compaction the you always
want it so leveled compaction typically
if you if you were to look at CF
histograms I have CF histograms later
you're you'll see the first column is
going to be the number of SS tables we
have to visit in order to satisfy a read
with size tiered compaction it's
typically you're going to see you know
it it'll end it will top out at about 12
SS tables and with leveled compaction it
will top out at three so with SSDs not
only are you is every sikh faster
you're doing fewer seeks because you're
visiting fewer SS tables so less work in
general so SSDs are a win-win-win
unfortunately a leveled compaction
requires about fifty percent more I oh
so if you're using mechanical disks you
won't be able to supply the throughput
necessary in order to do compaction so
you'll often see compaction was giving
behind if compaction is get behind then
performance is going to start to degrade
you can start running into garbage
collection issues so it's just not safe
under examiner you're in very specific
cases and yeah it just generally this is
the best way to go also in 20 the there
are specific enhancements for time
series data in regards to compaction
what we do is we look at the max
timestamp of the mint Ines stamp and we
decide is there any data within this SS
table that's still live if it's not then
instead of attempting to compacted with
another SS table we just unlike the SS
table delete it from the file system so
it mean essentially means that you can
get rid of compaction altogether if
you're using TTL s the the thing that
you want to do is you want to set a
default TTL on your column family
because that prevents you from having a
programming mistake and accidentally
inserting a column or a row without a
TTL which can prevent the T on the the
the SS table from being removed so
that's something that's easy to do from
an OP side and covers up bad code so
keep settings this is another one of
those things that people often get wrong
if you're running pure Cassandra 8gig
keep which in the default starting with
20 or 30 to 25 it will give you an eight
gig heap before it only go up to a Mac
so four gigs and this is a new one the
scripts won't do this for you but you
want to set a two gig music by default
it's going to limit you to 800 megs you
want to set that to two gigs and then if
you're you a DSC customer 14 gigs for
Maxie two gigs for the new heat and then
for Hadoop it's going to be 10 gigs okay
the reason why is that in Cassandra OS
are in DSC solar and solar and Cassandra
occupy the same jvm so in reality you
have three two or three applications
running within the same jvm so memory
consumption is going to go up so you
just want to have enough for the
overhead so monitoring off center use it
it's going to give you historical graphs
for all the information also going to
make it so that you can automate some
routine maintenance tasks so one of the
things that people often neglect to do
is run repair you if you run repair you
run the risk of updating consistency so
if a node were to go down cassandra is
only going to keep by default three
hours of data for the node that's damned
if you go beyond three hours then it's
just going to give up and when you bring
that node back into the cluster let's
leave it was down over a weekend or
something like that then that nodes can
have inconsistent results are
inconsistent data so how do we fix that
so first is the hints replication but
we're beyond that window second is read
repair but read repair only repairs rows
that are being read it's not repairing
roads that aren't being read and you
don't want data is magically coming back
from the dead let's say if it was
deleted so you run repair repair what it
does is it looks at the data on disk
computes a breaks it into chunks and
then computes a hash for each of those
chunks and compares that hash with its
neighbor if there is a disagreement in
that
that hash then streams over the
information so that you have full
consistency across the cluster now the
problem with repair is that if you have
data dense nodes then you're having to
compute these hashes across large chunks
of data and if there's let's say a one
Meg difference in a 10 gig chunk of data
while you're streaming over a large
chunk of information so you want to
break that into smaller and smaller
chunks in Cassandra 128 they added the
ability to run repair on sub-ranges but
calculating the splits for all those
sub-ranges is sort of a pain in the butt
it's and you you want to be running
repair on not all the nodes at once you
want to march it slowly around the ring
so incus in ops center 40 we've
automated this for you so you it's
called the repair service and so you
want to be running repair on the on
every node within your cluster every
nine days by default or within GC grace
if you're modifying can see grace ops
center will do that for you other things
that you can use to monitor what's going
on so this is what I go to first when
troubleshooting problems is CF
histograms so see if this is the the
view of the the what it looks like in
everything prior to two da dough into
know there's changed a little bit the
same ideas apply so this is a histogram
so this is my unit and the what the
value of the unit is
pens on which column I'm looking at so
in this one is how many SS tables add to
look at in order to satisfy the three so
I had four 3579 of my read so
essentially all the reads in this
example the offset is one so that means
just visiting one ss table if there's
two that I had 200 with two then I'd be
200 with two 200 requests required visit
to SS tables and the rest just visited
one with love of compassion that
shouldn't go ever go above three if it's
going about three then that probably
means you're falling behind on comp
actions with size tiered if it's going
about you should never go above 12 if it
goes above 12 then you're having trouble
with compaction and typically it's
either data models incorrect or your
their disk i/o issues now why easy real
easy you're in microseconds so the right
latency I typically like to see all well
I like to see the peak of the histogram
so if we were to graph this as a
distribution on a graph I'd like to see
the loop no greater than 150 micro
seconds this is because the right path
in cassandra is constant it's never
changing doesn't matter what underlying
storage media you're using is going to
write to the commit and then it's going
to update the mem table and only after a
certain that after the mem table reaches
a certain size then it's going to be
flushed to disk so we're writing to
memory for the most part so rights and
Cassandra are always fast their constant
they will never degrade in performance
as your data grows like it will with a
b-tree like it will with my seagull with
Oracle with with all these other
database technologies that use be trees
so
if we're seeing right Layton sees that
are super high that means data models
that knows them healthy disk is doing
something weird so it allows you to
narrow down the possibilities read
latency remains dependent on data model
and how many SS tables and data on disk
so the berries is going to be higher
there for s4 make my memory again I like
to see Reed's coming in at 130 to 150
micro seconds or less I mean you can see
reads as low as 30 6 30 microseconds per
read depending on how big the rose this
is excluding network latency by the way
so this is just within Cassandra itself
you know getting ready to respond for
ssds typically single-digit millisecond
less than five dependent on Rose sighs
if you're using mechanical disks it can
be all over the place it because a
single seat on a mechanical disc if
we're talking SAS drives it's typically
eight milliseconds it's a lot higher for
using SATA also the for ssds the
concurrency pipeline for my comedy
requests can I process in parallel for
an SSD is typically around six so if you
go over a number if you go over a queue
depth of 6 with an SSD then you're going
to start to see a pretty steep drop-off
in performance that drop-off in
performance is even more abrupt if using
mechanical disks and it's just horrible
if using side of disks you shouldn't be
using solid discs for the most part
SAS is really cheap so that you're just
going to run into a world of hurt if
you're running side of this these last
two columns are used for troubleshooting
data model issues so this can give me a
pyro size in bytes and this is going to
give me my Rose sighs in column count so
if if you see something here like I have
a single bro that's got 11 million
columns in the rest don't well join the
program info you know I think customer
they were doing they're using Cassandra
for doing spam analysis on email and
they and they were using a calling
family to keep track of what domains but
what email the domains the email was
coming from so we looked at at one of
them and they had crazy million hundreds
of millions of entries for this one row
as I asked him so what is that row and
they said it's google are you going to
blacklist google no then why are you
keeping track of a google bro right
again going back to performance tuning
the easiest way to get more performance
as a system is to do less work so you
don't necessarily need to track google
by every sink recipient that came from
google so remove that row from disk from
the remove that row our filter it out in
the application suddenly all the
performance issues went away because
they were essentially both updating in
reading from this very wide row with
every email ever sent from google or
gmail the next thing they like to take a
look at is TP stats so the the only two
sections that matter are this last one
it's all night long in this section
right here so
the most important one is mush writers
so you can see this one has on sun block
lotion essentially Cassandra attempted
to write to disk and couldn't so it gave
up that's probably going to be because
there is no corresponding dropped
message here that's going to be
compassionate starting to fall behind so
that you could be attempted that could
be two things you either could have
removed have a compaction throttle set
too high for your disk so like you know
sometimes people tick off the rate
limiter for compaction and there I
underlying IO can't support that so you
want to put a throttle back on for ssds
I typically start out setting into like
64 mags or they just they're running
leveled compaction and it shouldn't be
or they just need more I 0 for the what
they're pushing at the look at the
cluster they could or possibly add more
cluster nodes the other thing is the
communication so when Cassandra is
attempting to replicate a right from one
node to another it's going to come
across as a hint right cassandra is
going to prioritize requests that are
coming from the user / requests that are
coming via web application messages and
if there if the node is so bogged down
with client requests that it's having
trouble responding it's actually going
to drop replication messages coming from
the other nodes that will show up here
is joc mutations the only way that
you're going to to repair this
inconsistency is to read repair in
through repair those two mechanisms so
this is why you always need to run run
repair the other thing is that probably
means that your Cassandra cluster is way
too
way too small for the amount of that
you're pushing at it because the notes
just cannot keep up so people always ask
me what to monitor and this is what I
look for you can set alerts for all of
this in OP Center
I'm pending for all of the people taking
photographs yeah yeah also in the next
version of opscenter we're going to have
an agent that sort of looks for all this
stuff since you can define rules and
it'll look for misconfigurations and
weird things so best book ever for
trying to figure out like what's going
on in my system so my favorite tools r
io staff really iOS that's my favorite
tool because almost every issue that
every customer that come into they're
having issues with IO so it allows me to
find all the io issues and the most the
most important column in iostat like a
headless i do iostat space x space one
which is giving me the out the extended
output every second a weight because
that's going to give me the latency the
average latency for the sikhs for that
second and for an SSD you want to see
that less than one millisecond typically
is going to be point 1 or 100
microseconds or point 3 which is three
hundred microseconds every once in a
while you'll see it spiked up to six
milliseconds or 12 milliseconds but
should shoot right back down most of the
time it should be under one mil socket
so that's it questions I'm over
okay so you can tell pretty easily based
on the latency for that read so if it's
less than 100 microseconds then the only
thing only place it can come from is
from in memory if it's taking less than
eight milliseconds then the only two
places that can come from our an SSD or
in memory so you can take a look that
first and then the next one is you look
at iOS debt you just watch the output
and if you're seeing reads hit the disk
then you know that it's coming from main
memory sre if you if you're seeing reads
on the disks than yours you know it's
coming from the disk if you're seeing
reads if you don't see any reads than
you know everything is coming from main
memory what you can do is you can look
at the the throughput of your discs in
iostat and you compare that to the
throughput of the network controller and
from there you can say Oh seventy
percent of my reads are coming from main
memory of thirty percent are coming from
disk also in Cassandra 20 we keep track
of the amount of hot data and so you can
get that metric from jmx and from
CF stats as well like how much the data
is hot in that column family any other
questions so walking is walking it's
hard to track down so you can I mean you
can look at Hawkings hard to track down
without well first of all flocking is
verily the issue and the reason why is
because SS so in a petri you have to
lock a segment in order to modify it
right Sandra doesn't use be trees and so
once once an SS tables written it's
immutable so you don't necessarily need
a lock in order to in order to access it
the only time you would ever need to
lock it as if you're getting ready to do
compaction or something like that so
locking is very rarely the going to be
the issue or region right path now we're
locking can be an issue is between
different stages in the thread queue and
there is no good way to monitor that
without severely impacting the
performance of Cassandra because then
you're doing profiling
now it's not an issue never an issue
yeah never an issue it's there is a lock
1x door so yes and no there are it it's
using a concurrent one of the concurrent
Java structures well in the current can
we ship releases is using one the
concurrent concurrent dated Java
structures so it's using memory fences
in order to handle the concurrency there
instead of locking turnips like I mean
texture or seven floors I just because
you had a couple of questions I want
so if you're using loved compaction then
I want you see I don't want to see disk
utilization go above 75 percent if
you're using size tiered I don't want to
see disk utilization go about fifty
percent other questions yes so it does
take space it does get replicated so
what it's doing is all the counters that
use for graphing are kept in Cassandra
if if you have a larger cassandra
cluster than the performance of keeping
track of all those counters can have an
impact on the performance of your
cluster as a whole and so you want to
spin up a small cassandra cluster just
for dumping the data the other problem
is if your ring is going down for some
reason let's say yeah the massive batch
of SSD fails or something like that then
what you wanted you won't be able to get
to your data to see all the alerts
because the data is on the Cassandra
ring that's going down so by having it
on its own ring you're going to get some
additional availability
yeah because it's I mean it's monitoring
lots of counters at essentially i think
minute level granularity so it's I mean
that it's a lot of different counters
and it's going to take up space yeah all
right and then it actually captures the
data in the sea of staff would it be in
class VIII IV so it depends on your data
model the so what I would do in this
case is used tracing so we have tracing
built in to seek ulsh so if you want to
know why a particular query is running
slow hopin 2c qosh do tracing on execute
your query it's actually going to give
you a big dump of exactly what Cassandra
was doing and how many micro seconds for
each step so you can if your disk i/o
bound then you can see it there if we're
having to scan through massive rose
you're going to see it there so it's if
you're if you're trying to diagnose like
why a reed is why a particular Reed is
slow instead of like the cluster as a
whole then use tracing is that how can I
put it
34 of block or whether it is it like a
reed lead out you know for every single
idea does it read for one single quarry
how is it how big a case well so you you
want to look at your data model so the
you know if we're your partition key is
going to determine you know how the data
is accessed your so that when you're
creating a column family the two most
important things that you need to know
are the cluster column which is going to
determine how the information sorted
within the row and then the partition
key which is the primary key for that
route the primary key is used to
determine how it is distributed around
the cluster and then the cluster column
is used to determine how the day is
distributed within a row you want to
make sure that you want typically a
partition key that is granular as
possible and still enabling your use
case and then you want to have a cluster
column that is going to be your second
most used query or is going to in imbues
sort properties that are important to
your data model so it we're starting to
get into a data model specific stuff and
word I mean we're way over or like 20
minutes over at this point so if you
want we can step out in the hallway and
we can talk about specifics